من روما معنى
رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطاليه للجيو
فيزياء
والبراكين دكتور هل لنا ان نفهم اكثر ماذا
يعني ان تركيا انزاحت
ثلاثه امتار باتجاه
الجنوب الغربي
مسائكم اولا
الصفيحه
الاناضليه
تتحرك كل يوم
بمسافات قليله
بضعه سنتيمترات في السنه تجاهها الجنوب
الغربي لكن الصفيحه
الاناضوليه في في الجانب الشرقي من هضبه
الاناضول القريبه من الصفيحه العربيه
اذا في هذه المنطقه التي هي
كما قلنا
قريبه من الصفيحه العربيه القشره اكتسبت
واختسمت كميات كبيره من الطاقه اذا في
الوقت الذي كانت فيه هي الصفيحه تتحرك نحو
الجنوب الغربي
والتماس مع الصفيحه العربيه كانت الحركه
هذه
تكتسب وتغتسم كميات من الطاقه التي تم
اطلاقها بشكل مفاجئ لان
حجم هذا في هذا المكان لم يستطع استيعاب
المزيد من الطاقه اذا هناك عده
التصدعات
ظهرت لتسريب والتنفيس عن هذه الطاقه
وكذلك فان الحركه هذه
التي هي كانت ثلاثه امتار نقول بالحد
الادنى ثلاثه امتار ربما مع الهزه
الارتداديه الثانيه الرئيسيه التي
ربما كان الانزياح برمته من الناحيه
النظريه يمكن ان يكون خمسه او سته امتار
حتى اذا
الثلاثه امتار هي الحد الادنى التي
استخرجناها من حساب البيانات
في الهزه الارضيه في الايام القليله
المقبله عندما تتوفر البيانات من الاقمار
الاصطناعيه ستعطينا المزيد من التفاصيل
حول حركه الانحياز هذه بين الصفيحه
الامازوليه والصفيحه العربيه طيب ما هو
تاثير حركه الانحياز هذه
او الانزياح عفوا
الحركه هذه امر طبيعي تماما لان كل الهزات
الارضيه تؤدي الى حركات بين الجانبي او
جداري
الصدع او الخط الزلزالي واذا ما تتذكرون
حول زلزال طوكيو في 2011
الذي ضرب اليابان من جهه المحيط الهادئ
فان الحيازه قاع البحر في بعض الاماكن
بلغت حتى 50 مترا خمسين متر امر مثير
للذهول اذن ثلاثه امتار هي في ايطاليا
ايضا في 2016 الزلزال ايضا احدث حركه
بثلاثه امتار كان نوعا مختلفا من الحركه
لكن على اي اتحاد من الحركه ليس امرا
غريبا او كبيرا عندما
يتركز الزلزله ويكون الزلزال في صدع معين
وعلى بعد مئات الكيلومترات عنه هناك صدع
اخر
هل هذا يؤثر على صدوع الاخرى يعني زلزال
مثلا كهرمان مراش هل بالضروره يؤثر على
صدوع موجوده في في سوريا وفي لبنان
هذا ما نسميه بسلوك بؤره الزلزال او مركز
الزلزال عندما يتم اطلاقه تنفيس هذا الكم
من الطاقه يكون قادرا على تحريك اماكن
اخرى من الغلاف الارضي او القشره الارضيه
التي تكون في قد وصلت كتله حرجه من الطاقه
وتخزين الطاقه لان اي مكان
تضربه هز ارضيه يكون هناك تخزين للطاقه
الذي يولد الضغطه عندما يصل عتبه معينه
فان الهزه الارضيه تتم او تقع ربما يكون
هذا بسبب هزار سابقه تؤثر فيها وتحدثها
اذا
حتى
حتى في زلزال ازميت في 1999 في شمال غرب
تركيا
خلقه والله مجموعه من الهزات الارتداديه
بعد شهرين في هذه الحاله الهزه الارضيه
والزلزال الثاني كان اقرب من حيث الوقت
حوالي عشر ساجات بعد عشر ساعات تقريبا
طبعا هذه بردها الى ان بالنسبه
للكره الارضيه الثواني والدقائق والايام
كلها لا تعدو كونها شيئا صغيرا جدا من حيث
تخزين الطاقه التي يتم على مدى الاف
السنوات شكرا لك من روما
ليوني رئيس المعهد الوطني الايطالي للجيو
فيزياء والبراكين